chemise claire costume sombre
takeshi kitano arbore dans la vie la
même élégance hors du temps on l'a même
impassibilité énigmatique que les héros
de ces films flic solitaire voyous
vengeurs ils sont comme absent à eux
mêmes
samurai désespéré qui s'accrochent à
leur cause à leur code d'honneur comme
un naufragé good sauvetage m'a donné
l'ordre que tu as tu une balle dans la
tête
ta personne n'est dérange
et d'autre part il doute de ma loyauté
du mois
et toi
monsieur le frère avec des mots qui nous
entraîne sur les traces de 12 ans
on aurait tous mourir si je dois mourir
je mourrai
ces progrès
mamadou
ouais
je
il doit être emmené avec moi je pren ait
fait impossible intermédiaire entre
l'orient et l'occident entre le passé et
l'avenir
kita l'on continue de tracer son chemin
un chemin pavé d'une tendresse pour ses
semblables aussi profonde qu'elle
professe son désespoir